ينضم الينا المتحدث الرسمي باسم المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه فادي العبد الله مرحبا
بك سيد فادي على شاشه العربيه ما الذي
يعنيه قرار الجنائيه الدوليه بهذا القرار
على بوتين وايقافه وهل هذا يمكن ان يتبعه
اجراءات اخرى
مساء الخير من
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه عندما يصدر امر
بالقبض على مشتبه به فهذا يعني ان القضاه
يعتبرون ان من الضروري ان يمثل امامهم لان
هنالك
ادله تكفي في المرحله التمهيديه للاشتباه
به ولكن هذا ليس حكما بالمسؤوليه الحكم
بالمسؤوليه يكون بعد مرحله محاكمه اذا ما
وصلنا اليها لكن في هذه المرحله بناء على
التحقيقات التي افتتحها المدعي العام
بعدما تلقى احاله من 43 دوله منضمه الى
نظام روما فهذه اول قضيه متعلقه بالوضع في
اوكرانيا مثل ما ذكرتك اوامر هي ما يصدره
القضاه ولكن تنفيذ هذه الاوامر كما ذكر
رئيس المحكمه نفسه هذا امل يعتمد على
التعاون الدولي فالدول التي هي منضمه الى
نظام روما عليها واجب قانوني بالتعاون مع
المحكمه والقاء القبض على المجتمع بهم اذا
كانوا متواجدين على اراضيها اما الدول غير
المنظمه الى نظام روما فهذه لديها الحق في
ان ترفض التعاون او ان تقبل بالتعاون
روسيا نفسها غير منضمه للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه لذلك روسيا تقول ان هذا القرار لا
قيمه له بالنسبه لها
علينا ان نميز بين موضوعين الموضوع الاول
روسيا ليست منضمه الى نظام روما الاساسي
فهذا يعني ان روسيا ليست ملزمه بالتعاون
مع المحكمه يمكن لها ان تتعاون بشكل طبيعي
واختياري ولكن ليس عليها واجب قانوني
بالتعاون النقطه المختلفه هي موضوع هل
قرارات المحكمه من الوجهه القانونيه سليمه
وهذا يعتمد على ما نسميه في القانون
الاختصاص اي صلاحيه اجراء التحقيق
والملاحقات هذه الصلاحيه تملكها المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه بناء على اعلان اوكرانيا
نفسها مرتين في السابق قبولها بان تمارس
المحكمه الاجتماعيه الدوليه اختصاصها على
الجرائم التي يمكن ان تقع على اراضيها او
من قبل مواطنيها بالتالي الجرائم التي
تحصل
على منضمه او دوله قبلت اختصاص المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه هذه الجرائم يمكن لها ان
تخضع للملاحقه امام المحكمه الدولي
ه وما اذا كان او المجتمع بارتكابها
ان المحكمه يحق لها رغم عدم عضويه روسيا
ان تلاحق بوتين بالفعل
هذا الامر يشبه ما يمكن ان يحصل في اي
مكان من العالم هذا ما نسميه
ارتباط الجريمه بمكان وقوعها بمعنى ان
المحكمه المختصه يمكن ان تكون محكمه
الجنسيه الشخص المشتبه به ولكن يمكن لها
ايضا ان تكون المحكمه المختصه نظرا للعامل
المكاني وبالتالي الجرائم التي تقع في
اوكرانيا ممكن ملاحقتها اولا من قبل
المحاكم الاوكرانيه ولكن ايضا اوكرانيا
منحت هذه الصلاحيه للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه فبالتالي المحكمه لديها هذه
الصلاحيه كانتداد لعامل الاختصاص المكاني
في هذه الحاله بغض النظر عن جنسيه الشخص
المجتمع به سيد فادي هل يعني هذا ان بوتين
اصبح ملاحق قضائيا بمعنى انه يمكن ان يتم
القبض عليه في زياره ما في جوله خارجيه ما
لاي دوله هل هذا يعني ان هناك قيود على
سفره
من الناحيه القانونيه هذا يعني انه مشتبه
به في ارتكاب جرائم حرب تتعلق بالترحيل
القصري والنقل الاطفال مثلما ذكرتم وهذا
يعني ان المحكمه يمكن لها ان تطلب من اي
دوله منضمه نظام روما ان تنفذ هذه الاوامر
اذا كان الاشخاص المشتبه بهم على اراضيها
اما الدول غير المنضمه الى نظام روما فهذه
يعود لها ان تختار التعاون او عدم التعاون
طيب هناك اصوات في روسيا تتعالى وتتحدث عن
حياديه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في
العديد من القضايا الاخرى التي تقول ان
اوكرانيا ايضا ارتكبت جرائم حرب فيما
يتعلق بمعامله الاسرى الروس كيف يمكن الرد
على هذه الامور
القضيه التي اعلنا عنها اليوم هي اول قضيه
يعلن عنها في اطار التحقيقات في اوكرانيا
ولكن التحقيقات مستمره والمحكمه تحقق بشكل
محايد واذا كان اي احد لديه معلومات عن
جرائم قد ارتكبت من طرف او من الطرف الاخر
فيمكن ان يتواصل مع مكتب المدعي العام من
اجل ان يتقدم مدعي العام اذا ثبت لديه هذه
الامور بطلبات مشابهه لما حصل
الى القضاه كي يصدر عندها اوامر بالقبض او
اوامر بالحضور نعم السيد فادي العبد الله
شكرا لك على هذه التصريحات الخاصه للعربيه
المتحدث الرسمي باسم المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه فادي العبد الله